maintenant là
quand ça va bien
on n'est jamais si bien on n'est jamais
si tant il que dans la compagnie de son
dieu est là messieurs je vous présente
sweet dit sweety un berger allemand de
sexe féminin d'air généralement je suis
pas si samedi
elle m'a été donné par mon ami b luz les
chenils de lescar à côté de pau peut
dire d'elle qu'elle est une germaneau
berman est juin germanor béarnaise en
quelque sorte
alors suite pourquoi sweet parce que
paris c'est un fichier à pedigree
personnellement je dîne n'attache aucune
importance à ce genre de choses mais
puisque c'est ainsi il avait c'était une
année où les noms devaient commencer par
s alors c'était un sierra de margarita
de bellus de marché c'est très compliqué
roger lee sweatt voilà
tant canadiens
on n'est jamais dit
jamais dit dans l'île
je m'interdis moment super mamie peu
près de la cheminée dans mon camp
ont déjà payé
que dans la compagnie de son frère sweat
et une anarchiste total si bien que ce
qu'elle voit des gens avec des micros
avec des caméras tous à cette agitation
si ça ne lui plaît pas elle s'en va pas
question de dire ici
elle vient pas l'obliger à une seule
personne c'est ma mère
sweet est tenu à l'écart battable de la
chambre et lui
moi j'aime ça ne choque pas que déjà en
couche avec leur chien
on y trouve une place à leur table mais
non j'allais dire chacun à sa place
voilà sa place de chiens dans la famille
est ce que ce sera utile aux comme les
êtres humains elle mort quand est
angoissé ou malheureuses et je crois
qu'il pendant et c'est un chien heureux
quand elle retrouve ses babines sais
c'est pour rire fait chaud c'est trop
chaud il fait trop chaud ici fait
beaucoup trop chaud c'est pas un temps
de chien ça il n'y a personne qui est
toujours en vie d'un chien et d'un gros
chien c'est comme ça ça doit dépendre de
l'enfance et pourquoi un gros chien
mes parents sont originaires de la
vallée d'aspe et comme dans toutes ses
valets là on fait de l'élevage
principalement et le chien est vraiment
j'allais dire une personne c'est le
chien est aussi important qu'une qu'une
personne parfois plus
j'ai tellement eu d'admiration quand
j'étais enfant quand j'étais jeune voir
travailler six chiens dans la montagne
obéir à des ordres très compliqué passez
par là par derrière eux montent
descendent ne mord pas à bois oui aussi
aussi compliquée que sa part lancé c'est
à bois et le mot repas pique ça veut
dire tu peux y aller tu peux membres bon
si chien étant d'aider des
collaborateurs de l'homme tellement
merveilleux que c'était ce genre de
chien qu'on voulait chez moi on rien
seulement il faut il faut quand même pas
les rendre malheureux un chien comme ça
un appartement ça existe je ne sais pas
peut-être qu'en dise on est tout petit
là dedans possible qu'ils s'habituent
mais enfin moi j'imagine est un chien
mais dans la verdure dans les arbres en
liberté et dès que mes goûts vont amener
à pouvoir avoir de l'herbe des arbres de
la liberté bien on en a fait profiter un
chien ça fait à peu près quinze ou vingt
ans que chez des chiens
qu'est ce que vous pensez des gens qui
abandonnent leurs animaux lorsque ça les
arrange pour pas exagérer en disant que
c'est criminel ça dépend de quelle façon
l'abandonnent c'est vraiment d'une
inconséquence incroyable le type qui
abandonne son chien
un animal ça peut être un [ __ ] ça peut
être un écervelé aussi c'est peut être
ça peut être en inconscient c'est en
tout cas pas quelque chose de très bien
il ya un candide urria cas où il ya
kpama jacquat pas avoir de chien il faut
réfléchir tout comme les enfants
pourraient dire pour les enfants aussi
comme tous les êtres humains on est
sensible à l'amour qu'on a pour vous et
non ça peut être un animal alors voir de
quelle façon un chien vous regardez
quand vous voyez ce que vous représentez
pour un chien et quand ils vous
regardent avec autant d'amour quand il
vous fait pareillement fait quand vous
rentrez c'est quand même touchant c'est
bien agréable
j'ai des enfants bien sûr je préfère mes
enfants là aussi je connais les genre
d'argument hitler a pleuré pour son
canari il avait pas grande pitié pour
l'humanité ou bien au lieu de vous
occuper des animaux vous feriez mieux de
vous occuper les petits enfants ceux qui
souffrent pour ceci n'empêche pas cela
et dans certains cas je connais des gens
qui ont tué des enfants qu'ils ont
perdus ou quand un chagrin la présence
et l'amour d'un animal peut remplacer en
tout cas ne pas nuire l'amour d'un être
humain
ça me paraît évident et non il faut
croire qu'il est juste un paradis où se
retrouveront les hommes avec les animaux
qui sont aimés rui il ya un paradis pour
les animaux puisque il y à un banni pour
les hommes et on s'y retrouvera tous